[Music]
a century ago one hundred thousand
tigers roamed the earth
today those numbers have declined to
just about four thousand
but in the forest of eastern thailand
conservationists have found new signs of
hope for this iconic species
[Music]
this great big story was made possible
by
be grim empowering the world
compassionately
until recently it was believed that the
eastern forests of thailand didn't have
enough wild tigers to maintain a
breeding population
but a group of conservationists led by
panthera the thai department of national
parks and the freeland foundation went
out into the jungle to find out for
themselves
we set up around
83 stations of cameras each station has
two cameras
the general goal of setting up that
camera trap grid was to estimate how
many tigers are there what potential is
there for them to recover in that area
camera trapping is always fun because
you have these cameras out for 45-60
days in the field and they're out there
every day taking pictures so you bring
them back and you've got you know lots
of people looking at all the photos
clicking through what's next what's next
what's next
we discovered that we have
a breeding population of tigers there
this is kind of the first evidence of
breeding for at least i think a decade
it's a really
amazing thing to have been able to see
and to document
[Music]
tiger's a symbol of a healthy intact
ecosystem
to have tigers disappear from the wild
especially when we have the means to
stop that from happening would be an
absolute tragedy
[Music]
so although the survey results are great
news
we really do need to keep keep the
pressure on i mean there's the threats
aren't necessarily abating at those
areas so the good work that's continuing
with patrolling on the ground law
enforcement working on trying to give
tigers a chance to breed to have the
area they need to persist is really
important
[Music]
you